you
hi everyone is Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played in New York
1963 in a skittles room so this was just
a casual game between Bobby Fischer
playing on the white end and Rubin fine
so let's dive in and see how this one
played out a 17 move kill b4 is what
denotes the Evans gambit what is white
getting for giving up upon well as per
usual with the gambit some speedy
development to be a bit more specific
regarding this gambit white is looking
to overtake blacks strongest pawn or at
least challenge it quickly the e5 pawn
without the e5 pawn around this means
that the King Knight one of the things
this can mean is that the King Knight
will not feel so secure on its favorite
square like Han give it a shove with e5
moreover the Queen now has a path to b3
after this c3 move and Y can coordinate
well against blacks most sensitive
square F 7 okay in the game its Bishop
a6 this is considered most popular
second most popular is to drop the
bishop back to e7 continuing we have d4
sure enough and after a capture white
cannot be recapturing and forming a pawn
duo but White has gained something in
that the pawn is no longer on e5 and
from here white now gets castled so
there is no longer this pin and given a
move White is ready to recapture on d4
in this game Rubin is a bit hungry for
pawns capturing on c3 may be a bit on
the greedy side right
white continues with queen bee three
sure enough making use of this post in
applying pressure to f7 this can only be
defended with the Queen and it becomes
already very important
what square the black queen go to
best is considered Queen to f6 here but
you know there's still a lot of pressure
that white can be putting on black if
Queen f6 is played in this position in
this game is Queen to e7 so keeping open
the f6 square for the knight white is
now the side who is better Knight takes
c3 and if this game is to continue black
and needs to do well it needs to make a
capture on c3 in this game fine under
appreciates the strength of the Queen
night arriving on the d5 square in
connection with a pawn on e4 yeah this
is a big problem the knight needs to be
addressed it needs to be taken out isn't
in this game instead Knight f6 in a way
maybe trying to offset the knight but
why can now just hop in to d5
after Knight takes Knight how would you
recapture feel free to pause the video
okay
the best way to recapture is with upon
if you capture with a piece it's true
this diagonal stays open but what's more
important what's most important in this
position is that you dictate play you
throw punches in this open position and
make use of this superior development
the best is to take with the pawn the
move played in the game throwing a punch
and most importantly allowing now a path
for the remaining pieces to work with
the rooks will now have an open E file
95 in the game night is captured
development with tempo and this Bishop
now points at g7 Queen must defend Queen
actually has two important jobs
first and foremost defend g7 and another
watch over III the Queen can quickly
look to attack along the e-file
White is already in a position to give
up some more material giving up the
exchange just to have the Queen both
bishops and a Brook attacking the King
look at these guys on the Queen side not
contributing at all from here we have a
deflection tactic H for Queen s to make
a decision give up defense of g7 or e3
in the game its Queen takes h4 if let's
say Queen to g6 this is what y could do
as a follow-up
give a check and then get in along the
e-file in this game will be ending soon
computer suggests Queen b6 is best to
hold on
but yeah this is a million seven here's
one quick way that the game could end
pick your favourite way you have a few
different mates from here that one's
pretty slick anyhow in this game we
don't have Queen g6 Queen takes h4
instead and now in comes Bishop takes g7
that's like the two point pawn just went
down
how healthy are these two not very
healthy they're now isolated rook g8
now repeat one a
captured fine doesn't go ahead and
capture the rook but even if he did the
game would have ended in this in a
similar way King to d8 in the last move
of this game feel free to pause the
video and see what Fisher did next okay
in the game we had another deflection
tactic just as h4 deflected the Queen
away from observing both III and g7 well
the Queen has a very important role of
defending the f6 square here Queen g3 is
the final move of the game fine resigns
what's the idea well Queen takes Queen
that's checkmate
no need to even have a queen in this
position the King is very short on
squares so a quick kill here there is no
other move for team black computer says
Queenie 7 is best but yeah of course we
could just take the Queen and we're
winning in this position as well
actually a matin - what can insist on
this same idea with Bishop f6 but this
is as far as it went
in this Evans gambit very sharp opening
and well as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comment
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away from it
that's all for now take care bye
you